seriously Tik Tok Tik Tok took down my
video discussing my journey with Eden
disorders because it violates Community
guidelines took my video down because it
promotes negative social comparison when
this entire app is about social
comparison yet I post a video of Hope
discussing Eden disorders in an
educational way sharing my story and you
take that down yeah we need to talk
about this the fact that I need to
whisper the words when I am using my
expertise and education as a dietician
to take down damaging Pro content on
this app no different than Michaela
using her huge platform to share her
experience recovering from her past and
if we don't it gets flagged and taken
down for violating Community guidelines
and yet this content continues to rise
and thrive in the algorithm what is
going on here I am trying to lead the
troops over to the safe side of Tik Tok
but I can't do that if I need to censor
everything that the video is about like
how are my recovery friends going to
even find me if I cannot mention
recovery there are some days when I am
just done